all right uh two arrivals magnus carlsen
hikara nakamura
and uh we were talking about their
rivalry it started with some twitter
banter
uh and we did have that game in st louis
at some point when
hikaru showed up with sunglasses and uh
yeah look at that
we have a picture of that that sort of
shocked the chess world why everyone's
like why on earth is sicario playing
there with sunglasses
and you said it david i think he
explained it was something to do with
poker
he didn't want to give anything away i
don't know how that game ended though
but uh i think the thing is though when
when someone is going to such lengths
like you don't normally play
chess with sunglasses on i mean it's
probably going to be more of a
hindrance to yourself rather than your
opponent
yeah um i'm surprised it's even allowed
actually wearing sunglasses for some
reason i don't know
um but um either way i think nakamura he
didn't win that game i'm not sure if
magnus won but
nakamura didn't win that game because
actually for a long time um he just
he never beaten carlson in classical
chess carlson i think
at one point had even a 12 nil lead in
their head-to-head decisive games
lots of draws obviously but 12 nil is a
long way to go and uh okay nakamura did
eventually win one game against carlson
in classical chess but um yeah i don't
think it was this game yeah at least
fun by akara though shaking it up you